yeah now you you thought you were here
today just do like a little piece of
camera and tell everybody about the
sport yeah I've got news for you I'm
here with a special delivery I have
something behind my back yeah bono
courtesy of everybody else it's not a
bunch of flowers but i'm here to present
you with these sports personality of the
year award thanks very much how does
that feel yeah British food hey take it
all in stride look guys expecting to
scream all over there you go making
great challenges and my name's Ben I'm
gonna be yet hosting on the night I'm
from Parma no 5.5 I'm sure you're a
listener yeah of course right my dad
with the free sat in the radio athletes
think how does it for you yeah really
with you yes it's a real surprise what's
have been getting you to do you had to
like do loads of stuff just ran a
reservation the gym yeah few things I
guess yeah well many congratulations
yeah you've probably done it auto camera
before anyway but don't tell us a bit
more about this what I don't know too
much about Bob Scarlett and tell us what
it's all about a glorified sled
basically yeah hurtling down hill 80
miles an hour 80 90 and the new track 5
g's no brakes basically just a pompous
scary Barry took to begin with it is
absent you get something we controlling
yes absolutely fine how did you get into
it cuz I kind of have visions of you as
a youngster stealing trays from your
mum's kitchen and take them to the top
of a hill puttin underneath yourself and
like sliding down the hill but I guess
it didn't start that I did it um
strangely enough it did kind of there
are a few pictures of me about 10 years
ago yeah just on select just going down
here of course they melt the sport was
it happen yeah but now as universe do
buff accounts printing today yeah and
they were looking for people basically
as I finish University so I just
I went from six Rangers coming now you
obviously trained in here at you know at
the moment and yep what kind of trains
you need to do for it for a sport like
this and there's an awful lot of health
strength and conditioning stuff sale of
sprint wire and Jim were getting
stronger quick and then the rest of it
is all kind of mental preparation
there's every every track in the world
it's different corners as different
challenges where to then memorize each
track there's an awful lot of kind of
mental agility learning exactly what
what attracts them throughout you and
out steer it and what do you have to
kind of practice the the boxcars inside
of oh so you can eat yeah there's really
no I fear no exam yeah our first month
of belief season around Octavius all the
time it's spent out the Iceland Norway
Austria Germany yeah and that's not
gonna put a season stuff so we get me I
used to be a micromass load again and
our races kicks off end of november yeah
and you've always had quite a successful
year just just tell us about some of the
events you've been out and take apart um
well I've learned the three of those bad
where came second original championships
are one of those championships as well
which depends on the current will
champion is pretty good yes and then
hopefully this year will be will be a
look again there's six of us fighting
over three sports yeah selections we've
just had word for a competitive and so I
think I'm definitely in the mix together
so fingers crossed keeping everything
crossed yeah just finally as I know you
want to get on any words of wisdoms or
any budding athletes anybody perhaps he
wants to take up the Bob skeleton yeah
always always been open to new ideas I
never in my wildest dreams thought I'd
end up doing skeleton it's education if
you if you are involving sporting your
love bein sport and keep fit and just
keep keep going don't ever give up sorry
to find you absolutely breathe once
again many congratulations david swift
this is Sports Personality winner